i understand there's a lot of changes
that are happening like you said you
ditched the desk you're in this
beautiful vibe
and you have new writers that are more
gender balanced diverse
is this going to bring more of your
authentic view into season two
yes and no yes because i do believe that
inclusion
and a writer's room and a crew and a set
looking like the world is important i
think it's important to have all those
povs and
honestly it's just the environment i
want to be in i want you know to reflect
the world
but the reason i say no is because it's
not up to my writers and my crew and all
that to
bring my authentic self to late night
it's up to me you know and i think
it's my responsibility to do that this
is the jungle gym
treehouse and the writers actually work
out of the treehouse which is super rare
and for a show to let them see sunlight
during the day so how is season two
going to be different from season one
so many ways for one to see my outfit
yes for season two i actually had a suit
picked out for this interview and i just
walked into my hair make room and i said
you know what today i'm feeling
more like just casual and more meat and
so i literally just didn't wear the suit
and wore this and that's the vibe for
season two in general
whatever makes me thrive me feel
comfortable me feel like myself is what
is going to happen
or shooting in a house not a studio i
am kind of merging some of my youtube
attitude into this
show in the sense of like not having to
hit a mark and be perfect
not having to redo things if i make a
mistake i'm embracing mistakes
there's no audience obviously because of
the world but the crew
is my audience i'm interacting with the
crew i'm having banter with my sound guy
every episode at minimum is gonna have
one sketch in season two that is my
guarantee
yo put your hands in the air if you want
a late night show that nobody watches
cause they're asleep
[Music]
in terms of guests one thing i wanted to
change was yeah we want to hear from
celebrities and actors and actors and
musicians but
i also want to talk to people who are
not necessarily famous
but have dope things to say and are
doing great things you know there's so
many people
that have great initiatives or have
written great books are doing great
things in their communities
that have never had the opportunity to
be on late night and they have great
stories and they're the type of people
that deserve the platform
i love your energy there's something
different about you i'm prioritizing
having fun i think i
for so long believed that and i still
believe in the hustle and i still
believe in working so hard
and not being entitled and keeping your
head down and doing the work but i think
i didn't prioritize
fun as much before um
and i i saw it i saw it on the screen i
saw myself stressed i saw myself not
having fun i just learned when you have
fun
you truly don't have regrets